What did I do?
Why does it always come to,
that's one look and you're trying not to just to stir in eight weeks.
Yeah.
Sorry for waking you can I grandma always talk to grandma
c sat down
when I was a child.
I bought lucky bag every lunar new year from the stores back home.
They're full of surprise gifts to begin the new year with the fresh star and the
good fortune.
I know this is an important year for you,
so I prepare at lucky bag just for you.
Thanks grandma.
To open it yet.
Not until you really need it.
Okay.
Can I grandma?
I've always been a man with a plan.
Always repair number one to leave it to change,
but it's all in scripted when
it seems familiar.
Yet it all feels so new.
All of a sudden I'm
thinking about all of the things that we've been through.
It feels like baby,
I'm falling
to stone.
The
suddenly,
Oh,
you caught me.
So we fell in love.
So unexpected,
unexpected,
no money for five years and a day.
Never went.
Scott Ida,
these words to hold you and kiss you until the end of time and when you're
all the
things a week,
so you're going to ask you this.
Then that kind of,
what's that again?
Are you?
Yeah,
I'm feeling pretty lucky.
Last command if almost this weekend,
what is this
Jamie?
Talented,
smart and funny.
You are capable of doing so much more than you can imagine.
You don't need luck because it's what's inside that matters.
Katie,
I've had a crush on you this whole year had I just never thought I was good
enough.
Do these past couple of days,
I finally realized that
it's what's on the inside that matters.
You mind if I join you?
Heartbroken,
Huh?
Yeah.
I think I have just a thing for you,
the lucky bag and it helped me with on Katie.
Wait,
don't open it yet.
Not until you really need it.
Once you go,
give it a shot.
Thank you so much for watching what's inside and we hope you enjoyed it and
please make sure to subscribe the jubilee project for more films.
Also,
we want to give a huge shout out to Verizon for sponsoring this film,
but also for supporting jubilee project.
A Verizon has long supported the Asian American community and this lunar new
year.
They're actually giving out an exclusive lucky bag to make sure you check out
the link in the description below.
And finally,
we want to make sure that you send this video to as many friends and family as
possible because every view as this video will go to support an amazing
organization.
Learn more below as well.
But thank you so much for watching happy Lunar New Year,
and JP love.